Congratulations, you've reached
the end of this course.
I hope that you find it interesting and
informative.
And that the behavior of the internet
is a little less mysterious to you than
once it might have been.
I'm going to leave you with one more
story about the importance of speed and
network bandwidth to the users
of a web application.
I've put a link to it just below.
It's a story from Chris Zacharias,
a former YouTube developer.
He tells about how reducing the size
of YouTube's video viewing page
made the site much more accessible.
But also that it was hard
at first to see the effect
without careful measurement.
This story is worth reading and
thinking carefully about.
For anyone who works on large websites
or anything else bandwidth intensive.
Thanks for your time and
energy taking this course.
See you around.